a project I've been working on for
couple months first of all I just want
to include shout out to move again this
is a new main up something not from San
Francisco but it is started here in san
francisco by right Sarah Adams if you
are stressing again identify them you
may interested in total whether you go
so check them out so for those who don't
have my name is david i'm i'm here from
Australia my day job I work for
canonical working on a product with all
due to which if you're a large price
customer come talking about leg in my
spare time I could be like to go project
I I put on lots of arm 64
go under five or so tilton loop how pcs
important and also save a lot of time on
our cell so project I'm going to talk to
you about tonight is 4 GB which was the
thing that I read about four more than
you
talk to Billy and so most of you being
there x written on train between yung
berg and trilling gave a talk and this
is really to go to follow up to that so
Jimmy isn't off going the same way we
have to go to the key differences are
that basic is project-based merchants a
workflow choose a workspace placed one
of the key ideas is that we want to
provide people builds bias or entry
vector this is important because this
vendor e without rewriting ports and
lastly gb is a set of reusable
components and sort of the way that come
and go is not by come on go all the
logic is locked up you know I'm going to
make my package I think it's important
that there are set of libraries which
lets you build go
directly oh it's a house Jim different
well the first one is that it is not a
wrapper around go tool I think this is
an important differentiator Joe naps and
many of the other tools just wrap the
goes on that's fine but what I think not
wrapping go talk based on remitting
their lodging gives us for one it gives
us agility when you talk about building
code without having to fit it through
what can you expressly we go to all that
and kind of you know can try the go past
it and then that achieves what we want
the same point isn't user speed don't
wait until until the bowflex lands in
the next version of the go tool and if
you're unfortunate enough that your
company isn't chasing the bleeding edge
you may have to wait even longer so
having to think outside the first day of
library thing is that is an advantage
the last one is extensibility I thought
4gb and through command really which use
the big market interact with has the
seller has a set of assumptions which
I'll go through but you can take these
components and put them together and use
them to build effectively your own
builder when I was at gothic on last
week spoke to a man from a large
internet service provider who have a
very strange mandated like way they need
to have the frame the project now i cant
health and directly with GP what we want
to do is building stone but I suggested
to him that I will work with him to help
him to add the features to let him build
his home don't all using these
components the second thing is that
Jeanne doesn't use go path go path being
a workplace when he allows one copy of a
project and the dependencies moving away
from the going to actually means moving
weight and go back because they they've
had lead to greater and why wouldn't
want to do this because no part doesn't
actually hold a dependency management
this is pretty much why all or here
tonight to hear me talk brothers
how so delp see this is why it's a
project phases are quite useful as
opposed to using go path but first of
all is that it gives you an opportunity
to control all the source of your
project including the source that it
depends on in one place the project you
can have multiple working copies upon
this you can just change between them
this is very important to learn your
juju because we have to support four or
five for these branches currently so the
ability to be able to move between those
very good clean without any earlier is
really important to us similarly it
gives you please separation between the
code that you write and the code will
depend on and I viewing parties you've
tried to have Gopal's with multiple
elements prefer this I want to say this
is my stuff and this is the stuff that
once than somebody else no one ever
clear separation you can upgrade the
team on your schedule not when somebody
else bushes to their master and
similarly you can avoid being upgraded
by someone randomly when I push the
master and again pushing this message of
tools goes on about tools and gear we
beseech you
no importa right I hope so much about
this that was one of the major use of
vibrating its kind of you now because
the do we buy their experiments me they
all divided but the reason I left also
passionate about avoiding auto
brightness that will actually rise on
source code metrics Xavier also open the
future introducing with its mother and
if importantly read the source so they
came from their name to change that that
is removed as an option so I think no
important rewriting was learning 40gb
also it encourages this idea of project
of a project loaner the project owner is
responsible for emitting dependencies
into that project and secondly puree
denotes immunity sponsor is a real idea
of ownership and identify our project
now depends on this particular to
libraries my team droning something like
that and accepting that ownership
explicitly rather than just kind of
filtering in through someone adds there
and for mine then go and get pictures
employee
so I'm going to give a whirlwind tour of
GV and I'm going to do a live demo no
have some questions making TV project is
super simple any directory that has a
subjective word source is a jiffy
project that's all there is to it let's
just put a bit of sauce in there mr.
hello world type thing you do need to
put things inside packages in fact TV's
much stricter about this in the virtual
there is no option to build or run a
single file everything must being a
package we can cause it's important
because why you can use go run to run a
single file or to test a single file
that idea quickly runs out out of state
and so this is very much about
encouraging people with the right
behavior the little boy over head up
upfront into the right behavior building
it to build obviously um point when it's
the particles in the usual places
package for reuse later if you have
commands so it's been so being how the
world
GP has really good support for
incremental compilation and we've done
away with this idea of the having to go
build versus go install basically
anytime you build something where you
can test something if there is a recent
compilation that you've saved we save
that been so it's always just do you
there's no GP install
the usual things of juubi build a
particular path for sub path or a globe
or something like that is supported but
because incremental compilation so
strong you can basically said that
really the project we must keep doing
Jimmy building Jimmy test anything that
leads we built will be we made up to
date and obviously if you have multiple
commands that are found in project devil
so this just an example if only multiple
multiple commands the building indeed
the lay up our GT project very jealous
of their path name is all set up some
Turkey's my arms pero SI package for the
power of data files and probably a
veteran for me too
now Jim because we care how that's all
spot on this all it cares about is that
it's arranged in the lab expects this
part that i own apple for now it's a
pretty good idea that we pray when i
check this in the source control and the
simple answer that means you just check
the whole thing in you probably exclude
being packaged cuz they're just
temporary stuff and might want to use a
get ignored but you are working with the
root of the root of the project or way
so that's all going to be pushed into
one repository
now big any questions pendants
management
at the moment Jimmy's answer to MC
management is bender wholesale copying
the source that source goes into a
different a different area so rather
than project sauce goes into vendor
source and that that's how we get
separation between stuff if you've
written the stuff they're of delivery
you can do this manually if you like but
obviously we've written a plug-in so gb
vendor fetch the
11 of packages that we depend on them is
missing so command G SFTP needs give up
a package smtp gb venue fecha say we
also support recursive fetching someone
to the way that go get does and now we
can just build the whole thing pretty
uncommon for Don controversial obviously
once you've been dirt some code we
should add that I bet and commit all
that as well and then this becomes at
that point you are the project owner
this is this is part of the roller
pressure on you now have taken this code
and bought into a repository you now own
it there are various plans for updating
it that'll just pull that up to the head
of the head of the branch you got it
from the support branch and tag and
revision all these ones for customizing
the particular particular vision of that
part that you want a vendor obviously we
have delete and I'll show a few of the
other commands
TV also has the idea of an armed list
cuz you use the album goes the gobis
yeah so we haven't heard that the same
idea you can did this is the default
presentation but all of these are
sexually templated fields that you can
control so one request i had a while ago
was wrong something's coming from
bringing background in there is 0 there
are services which will look at your the
bundler depends file and kind of
advising it'll be depending on a mean
secure version should probably do
something about that so this is issue
tools to to kind of interact with the
manifest it's being recorded of the
dependencies you've ended
and so if you saw my presentation in
burley I was I was the person that made
a big big snake that there would never
be a manifest Africa for go projects
because nobody could agree on me on the
syntax and this is probably partial join
my excuse is that the manifest file is
only used by those plugin it's not
required to gb but there is no other way
there is no other place to put this
configuration information so the
manifest file is part of the vendor
plugin it's not used by GP again gb just
into the fire somebody because it here
how about there so I'm going to put this
microphone down bro what I'm going to do
is no ask someone in the audience who I
promise I have prepared to give you a
project that they've got so this is not
should be a library but it should be
something like a hub that is a package
that produces a set of code code that
reduces the binary and will try and
convert it into a gb project so you can
see see how that works someone got ya
down the front good training ok let me
just make this
Oh things ever up so go training
training lick it lick it up trendy okay
so
what's what's you are L
it's a friend's project
ok
we can do too is there anybody else
while we're yet down the back I gos you
are yep go rendered in store stock let's
go baby
okay that's that's cool
ok so let's have a look at
okay so this is good because it means we
can just ignore that we can you build
that fender we don't need that so
okay so you just move that up a bit so
the first thing we're missing is can we
store app package
okay sorry what I need to what I first
thing I need to do is move this to the
correct location where it needs to came
from so
yep I'll do that for you in one second
listening to get the dough sir
okay so
we just
Sean not coming that way okay Oh
okay so this is what it would look like
if this was an empty go and indigo path
so instead of the checkout being at the
roof we've moved it back into we moved
it back into the pathway which you'd
expect so reticent probably be important
github the Congo sorry you go store
store like fanfic so that's the first
step
ok
oh this is this is going to be terrible
because you've actually right you've
actually rewritten or being borders ok
cantonese you know sorry you rewrote the
imports it's impossible now ok I can't
hope
ok but so it's one
that that's an awesome okay
ok
so if we
okay so this has a pendency on go query
so we can go and get that
so
ok so we're catching the fetching go
query and as you can see it's got a few
recursive dependencies on Cascadia I
don't know that one and the net HTML
package so then if we there we go so
that is literally that is literally oh
it's required to convert your pack your
project from go gettable form to GV form
so
okay i don't have long time so quickly
by there
so wrapping up GD by the numbers we have
some stars I don't know what the current
exchange too serious a funding is for
that more importantly we have a bunch of
contributors I want to call out that
this in fact this is fantastic about 24
qubit is so far and this is I'm just so
thrilled to have people who engage with
this project before I open for questions
on ansys is the obvious ones first one
is how this GD handle design
an answer is that it is emerging
feminist they'd only be one of events or
cemented record so
these easily several gates in other
there's no way that the government is
not always making to insane set
back physically not possible so if you
find yourself Indonesian we're down one
frequency graph you need
drive back to another
do as programmers or attention to that
become just as a sales
the street
so that's that's how we get the proper I
wish you'd also be perfect that's
exactly going to
second one is how does all these changes
with the go under five experimental
element well the good thing is that
proposal was accepted and we have this
new experimental plane and in fact REM
recently thanks to Edward Miller go
dad's house applauds been to the vendor
subdirectory your go get ball repository
also many of the annoying things that I
complained about in Berlin have been
things competition is really good for
entities it turns out go get can now use
this disbanded don't users from our
vendor their dependencies into their
repositories it gets a little more
confusing when you go get one repository
that this code has very small stuff I
think that what gb does is much cleaner
in that there is no kind of recursive
searching for dependencies it's all in
it's all of my place but most
importantly it doesn't really
effectively because we don't use them
yet and gb projects and I forgettable we
still have our own idea of having a
project based approach rather than a
workspace so this is very like this
especially all the bully annoying bits
that have been fixed good to go
this is great you get them for free if I
didn't have to use GV but in terms of
how does this impact what we're doing gb
not a great deal and the life sont
energy encouraging to their library and
the answer is absolutely yes it can be
the difference between a project where
library is really doesn't produce a
binary or does it just have stuff that
other people going to share at the
moment to use one to vega 1gb project
into another here's a manual process
most of the support is there in the gb
vendor command it's just all the way up
yet so if you're passionate about that
raising issue from talk to me afterwards
or set patches and that's really all I
have um so just to recap project-based
perfect project-based so to replace I
supposed to say words based on workflow
knowing repeatable builds via sauce been
during without employed rewriting and
the thing I'm most like I'm most proud
about is we have refused posts that I
can come up with an answer to the tree
guy from the ice P who needed like
there's no way that any of the tools
that big proposed before the goat or
even TV kameez requirements but that it
there was a way for that he could we
consume the components of gb's may
dabble
um so I have a few little prizes for the
first question and a second question is
something you'll be the first one so one
of the players de Medici ok question is
one of the plants of cross compilation
we absolutely do what's important it's
it's just a matter of time I spent a lot
of time at arm so I I want this I want
this very much it is just a matter of
time be the vendor plugging actually
taking yet the vent plugin has been
taking a lot of a lot of them about the
time it was some time to do something
happen to push off to later I really
thought that I could hold the line with
using using kit gives up modules but
that didn't work so that so all these
things we absolutely collapsible and I
um I want have a really good story for
across inflation not just 15 those are
fun
jumping you were living I don't know if
you get a break away
decision
and she
have we never met before sir
joint Academy them so the question is
happening is a gb vendor to fetch a
particular provision or tag or something
like that um with a flag of course let
me
so just get a random hush
and
so what we're going to do is move the
hash this one back hopefully able to see
that back so first of all
if I type it quickly so remove that one
from the list and now
so the only difference before is that
compositing vision to say more
specifically you cannot see this is
after pins into the interpretation you
switch to the branch which is probably
better or tag
previously we're on vision 518 DD and
now we're here and you can see also that
rather rather than saying branch master
when I detached it a bit are you
accepting contributions
our lovely said contribution to place
called first before we started started
early fancy only with importantly big
fun my request so open issue can talk
about what you wanted is this kind of
works the same as the go project talk in
code to do it the other way around Mike
waste of time come back
I have seen no support however mated
with blood sweat tears I for for the one
boxing branch I really want to open
proposal that a lot of the logic that is
inside the go Margo until these is
pulled out some other people using
previously this was a bit of a problem
because in the standard library there's
a strong aversion to making new package
obviously sacrament forever now we have
methodologies like the eternal rewrite
and there are a number of bits of the
ghost also to maintain an external posit
reasoning coming back in the VCS lodging
which drives go get similar to that so
hopefully we can do something similar
with your way that the go build logic
works and force week
specific version
okay so the question is understanding is
I will be linking in a specific version
of again silly the question is how is
you can work independently from I'm
sorry I'm really comforted maybe we
should answer questions I think and that
might be the this is a really doesn't
think GT is closely tied to version of
go to compartment this is the most same
way to do it he comes out of the go-to
is also click has this close coupling
but kind of don't notice it because it
comes with the standard distribution but
for example support go under 405 we have
filled tags in building gb to alter its
behavior for the tool changer it's
working so when you install when you
know Jimmy it's customized for the
version of go to filters which I cope
successively a lot of the sea go
behaviour change between 14 and 15 and
at the moment it's in this case of
rebuilding rebuilding
retweet objects or even speak to me I
have one wonderful
15 I should probably talk some more
about this afterwards yes that's the
roadman the roadmap r is substituting
itself the has got two logs to build
into test that's all it does it was very
much an experiment to see how a build
tool could work in that kind of game
plug in nature like you see exactly same
methodology thing called Rick gb hyphen
becomes a plug-in eluded a dilute zoom
or copying coughing source barbarian
works it gives us it gives us the
repeatability that I suddenly need a TV
maybe there are other ways to do this
and hopefully through the plug in a
guide when reusing the components of
Jimmy that'll be useful
yes stand back
okay so quick the question is if we have
this manifest file which pretty much
describes exactly the thing we need I
don't while there we why why by the
protecting the source um this is sudden
very much personal preference on my
point of view and also wondering out the
GV vendor is a plug-in so if you wanted
to inspect it differently you can really
complain to do so i have a very common
feature request that comes up i keep
closing on GV people who like if you saw
how we can curse of the alleged offenses
you just need to know the name one and
you can fetch that whole arm also what
can we do just specially more you've got
other logically and my my resistance to
that is that that will do exactly what
going in does it fetches from head
because there's no other information you
can give it and if your and so that the
best things that
I just rewritten go again and we're back
in the same sittin sideways so I want
frigid owners to focus on the
responsibility of taking on depends
explore it's not a small I detective you
should consider it every time you you
you add them that's that's really my
answer tomorrow it is not a technical
orientation is just how i've chosen how
i think that go projects will be managed
and the the important bit is that you
can take all these tools and you can
build your own growing IV the you can
build your own plugin today doesn't it
need to live in the same possibly or
just needs to do a thousand Jamie hyphen
in our profession
code here yes Lashon
mhm
okay so
the question I understanding is if you
start to use GV on libraries like
multiple library
okay thank you at the moment it's quite
a mental process but to do some to
explain a little bit the target users
that I CCTV are people who are not
writing libraries but actually writing
applications and go that probably don't
produce pro binary or producer service
or deployed than summer so they really
then enters the end of the line of that
dependency chain you can use Jimmy for
libraries at the moment it's a little
bit hard drinking let me to close the
gap there with Jimmy vendor but
certainly the tiger one is I hadn't
minded people like myself working
tonight will have to support multiple
multiple ways branches the currently
multiple feature branches and there's no
other really achieved you do jeje
produces a client and server the dead
package that's last we hear so that's
the way that the type of Tiger market
they had
thank you okay let's call it here thank
you very much